missionary George's the jungle reboot
and then have them fight each other in a
versus film and then they'll team up in
the end no don't encourage them don't
besmirch Brendan Fraser's jungle
hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry so
Jerry and I have just watched the
trailer I saw it again for The Legend of
Tarzan I didn't have a chance to review
the trailer so I brought jerr-bear here
with me to talk about it I'm sorry I'm
something negative that's shot where Sam
Jackson whips out the guns like yeah I'm
like okay wait a minute
what looks like Abe Lincoln it's it's
distracting yeah it's like one of those
those weird shots you could tell is on a
green screen but it's like stylized
distracting because like if it was
another actor I probably wouldn't have
been so distracted sorry Samuel Jackson
you've kind of just developed that
regardless it still looks like it's out
of a different film at that point well
yeah because so much of this trailer
looks like you know kind of like the
more serious version of one of those
like we've taken a sort of story and
we've made it more real like it has that
sort of like it's like the dawn of the
Planet of the Apes version of that I
feel like they did I feel like they did
it like Disney's Tarzan and this is
their real life yeah well I heard it
might be closer to the book actually
half the trailer looks like this you
know serious like man versus the
elements versus man type movie with that
Sam Jackson shot it almost makes him
look like the like the mustache twirling
villain yeah you know like that
climactic fight with the villain who's
trying to steal all this money on the
train so yeah it does feel like it's
trying to be both weighty but also like
an action movie exact you know exactly I
don't want to be cynical you can almost
feel the elements of this that have been
pushed around by like you know
market-tested
yeah like this is a trailer so they're
gonna show you like there's a bunch of
sweeping spectacle which most of it
looks fantastic man yeah it's beautiful
every once in a while there is a shot
where I'm like that looks pretty like
the the one where he's swinging around
and that's a hard effect this is what
happened like with spider-man swinging
around not all the time but like
whenever they do a CG swing like the
body kind of stretches a bit too much
like howevers like it doesn't look quite
natural it looks more weird because if
you spider-man's at least in a costume
yeah it looks more weird because it's
just a dude shirtless yeah you know
I know he doesn't have shoes on [ __ ]
yeah I get it no no no underwear oh I'm
kidding
he wears Hanes you try and get placement
ya need some underwear daddy needs some
underwear the locations and stuff and
all the all the effects of course I'm
curious now because of you know King
Kong and Island stuff like what they did
seems some King Kong like I was like
this is straight out of Peter Jackson's
King oh yeah and there's another King
Kong movie so I'm sure they're trying to
ride in on that I'm wondering you know
did they mocap some of these creatures
it look like it did they use some
animatronics cuz there are a lot of
different ways to approach these things
I'm curious as to how they would have
done that cuz a lot of times the animal
effects look pretty good I'm just
curious as to you know what what level
of budget they had to really make these
effects incredible you know because this
seems like it might be a little bit of a
hard sell because you know Tarzan is
older school it's not exactly the name
everyone's gonna go like [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
a man what I hear is this - just how
many of the toys they had access to what
concerns me a little bit is that there's
so much spectacle and I'm like is Ida
okay
I'm not familiar with the original
Tarzan story however it's simply it's
The Legend of Tarzan and I don't think
The Legend of Tarzan was kept around
this story for so long because of like
sweeping spectacle I feel like there's a
story there well that I really hope they
put a lot of focus on instead of trying
to be a visually cool movie thing is
like a visually luscious movie like a
movie that's just chock-full of great
shots can be I guess can be that
Hollywood like oh it just kind of looks
nice
yeah but there's not much here but it
can also really enhance something that
has weight in it true you know and David
Yates proved that with the Harry Potter
films that he could thank your writing
Burroughs there you go that's who
created thinks I was really looking
forward to that information over this
but there's like at the time this came
to be and was written like these kinds
of stories were different you know
that's the time where you could still
have a reasonably affluent like very
Western guys like going on safari or
like doing a trip to the rainforest to
kill a wild boar for sport you know like
when you'd have like a study with
tusk doorways and like a fireplace in a
globe and [ __ ] it's of a different time
in those stories I'll have a very
specific aesthetic and I'm curious as to
how much of that we'll get with this
because it's that's the time in place I
would be interested in going if
something exactly you know exactly
people have said that it's supposed to
be closer to the books if that's what
like the time period it was written I
hope that they actually honor like
whatever it was at the book at that time
yeah that's a really smile that
adventure that's what I mean it in an
invention I want to feel the story I'm
not really I don't really care so much
about let's get some of the best visuals
ever I I really care more about like I
want the Tarzan story for sure I want
them to do the story and not do like the
dark gritty version yeah yeah well tell
the story tell it like it would have
been in one of those yeah exactly I
don't want it to try to be something
else
so let's modernize it in some ways let's
make this really like really pertinent
to like the kids who are 19 I like the
cast in it too I like like I liked the
actors I don't know if I'll like the
characters I just saw the trailer please
like I like the actors Christoph Waltz
seems like the perfect casting choice
for the kind of story Tarzan actually is
yeah like he would be the guy with all
the money funding the trip and like you
know coming along for the prestige of it
and I hope you know he gets to do
something like that because I think he'd
be perfect at it and I hope that if he
does become like the villain of the
story that he's someone that we can sort
of understand that he's not like hey I'm
playing a villain you know like twirling
is a passion [ __ ] the kind of guy who
would become a villain because he's an
opportunist and he is taking the best
investment you know yeah he's just doing
what he does he's not playing evil yeah
he doesn't view himself like a bad guy
yeah like I like those villains yeah I
do too I do do and I mean it's of that
it's a it's a little more of that time
to yeah I want to see Tarzan [ __ ] up
some animals remember that did the
cartoon when he fight fought that like
cheetah or some [ __ ] oh okay in the
beginning and they presented it to the
leader of the tribe and then he was like
whatever and then
was like man [ __ ] this [ __ ] and he
smoked a joint with the one that Rosie
over contemplate this remember the
animated film yeah
don't recall yeah yeah this water
sanitary it looks questionable to me you
know Moretti I think I didn't see Tarzan
I think I saw the trailer is a good
didn't ours that had to feel Colin some
yeah no I didn't see the cartoon was
confusing because Tarzan meets Jane and
then he's like hmm I'm hurt and I'm like
[ __ ] did you learn to say Tarzan and you
know but it's just for us unless you
know other explorers have been through
you know I don't know no yeah that movie
that was the first time he ever saw a
huge arguing about this yeah I like that
last shot I like that moment a dialogue
at the very end I mean you know Sam
Jackson getting to do his thing
yeah and Alexander Skarsgard getting
into his Eric thing yeah oh come on
cannot see past the vampire thing yeah I
got lucky because I only I only managed
to see the first season after like a
couple episodes of the second season so
well you missed all the gay sex II had
and the straight sex too well Oh
wonderful
you're so sexy and charming I want to
say I understood why Sookie was
sometimes going a little bit after bill
I mean after Eric because you know
what's like Bill's like more I'm like
the Civil War era well Eric's been
around for like ever and yeah you know
he has the perfect American accent he's
just so sexy and and I would imagine
that having seen True Blood you were
probably even more familiar with not
only like his face and his you know
general expressions but now you also
know his body so you have that much more
header voicemail Tarzan a shot
Tarzan a shot that that shot will decide
what kind of movie this yeah why does he
need a loincloth for just the [ __ ]
let him go naked well it's a patina to
protect things from the elements the one
little cloth has
well I mean using a work underwear under
that cloth at least you know like from
from when you think the other Apes of
point and laugh at his penis I don't
know I mean maybe because he probably
had a small penis compared to them well
but but here's the thing is didn't they
didn't they come across him when he was
we when he was a lad yeah so maybe it's
you know like maybe they laughed
initially but then as he grew like you
know his penis continued to grow with
him yo being my submitter they got used
to it by now and you know they respect
him you know no it wasn't like oh you're
freaky now that the mom took the baby
Tarzan in right away you'd see the
cartoon no no you didn't - gentle sub
scribe through the real rejects
mm-hmm-hmm reasons the G area on this
channel in dank ass dubs
podcast hosted by Jerry I feel like
Tarzan was bullied but hey yeah I feel
like he was just bullied like he was the
kid people bullied why I mean come on
like I'm look at him so he grew up in
and overcompensated by like getting buff
in super tow yeah I'm like really
working on himself in personal
development he listened to a lot of self
motivation I mean kind of I wouldn't I
wouldn't necessarily god that [ __ ]